This video explains how to
make comments on the proposed
submission Teignbridge local plan 2020-2040
the live consultation Teignbridge local
plan web page contains links to all of
the consultation documents including
the proposed submission local plan
if you wish to make comments on any of the
consultation documents so scroll down this
page until you see the start button, to begin
adding your comments click the start button
to comment you can log in with
your Teignbridge MyAccount
you can either create a MyAccount or continue
without one, please note that if you do not
have a MyAccount you will not be able to
save and return to your comments later,
before you are able to proceed you
need to read the Privacy notice
by pressing continue you are agreeing
to the conditions set out in this notice
please select whether you are an agent acting on
behalf of someone else or making your own comments
if you are an agent making comments on behalf of
someone else please fill in both sets of contact
details if you are filling in your own form please
include all your contact details as requested we
cannot accept anonymous representations
at this stage of the local plan process
you will need to select whether you wish
to comment on the local plan or Community
infrastructure Levy from the drop down menu please
select which part of the local plan or which
consultation document you wish to comment on you
can comment on specific aspects of the local plan
the whole local plan other consultation
documents or supporting evidence
you must then select which policy or proposal you
would like to comment on in the drop down menu
you are asked to comment whether you consider the
plan or policy to be legally compliant there are
many tests of legal compliance such as whether a
plan accords with national legislation has been
properly consulted on during its preparation
and has taken account of comments received
you are asked to comment whether you
consider the plan or policy to be sound
the national planning policy framework
sets out the tests of soundness to be
one whether the plan has been positively
prepared and meets the area's development needs
two whether the plan is Justified being based on
evidence and considering reasonable alternatives
three whether the plan is effective
and enables sustainable development
and four whether the plan is consistent
with national planning policy
you are asked to consider whether the
plan complies with the duty to cooperate
this duty ensures that neighbouring authorities
and certain statutory organisations are
involved during the preparation of the plan
consider that the plan does not meet these three
requirements you must explain your reasons why
if you have completed question three you
can also set out any modifications that
you consider would need to be needed to
make the plan legally compliant or sound
once you have written your comments you
will need to press the add comments button
when you have added all your comments you
will need to press the next button to continue
Community infrastructure Levy
or CIL draft charging schedule
review the proposed changes and indicates whether
you agree or not you will be asked if you wish to
appear at the examination hearing that will
be held by an independent planning inspector
if you choose not to appear at the hearing your
comments will still be considered by the inspector
before you submit your comments you will be
asked to complete some information about yourself
you can choose whether to provide
this information or not you must
then click the submit button to send us your
comments thank you for watching this video